in your 30s like you're a full ass adult
you can do whatever the [ __ ] your mom
directly in her eyes and say my being
needed attention
you want to read it
hi Matt and Chris I love you and I love
Calvin too okay I am extremely
embarrassed I'm one of my early 30s and
I still live at home with my parents and
younger brother the other night I was in
bed watching some
naughty videos
I had my airpods connected of course
what I was completely unaware of was
that my phone was also connected to the
Bluetooth speaker in my all caps parents
bathroom
I didn't know your phone could be
connected neither did I do two devices
at once but apparently it can crying
clown face my regular face oh regular
crying face uh my mom confronted me the
next day to ask if my phone was hooked
up to the speaker and I checked and
still unaware of the major atrocity said
oh yeah oops it didn't hit me until she
said I noticed it last night
shock face oh God I want to die I want
to fly to outer space and never return I
want to change my identity and only wear
wigs from now on what do I do do I leave
it at that do I confront her about what
exactly she heard please help shoot me
love you now just honestly this the
advice I have is you didn't do anything
wrong no you didn't you made a mistake
by having your parents hear that [ __ ]
but you didn't mean to
um but like the whole shame of it is
like you don't need to feel that there's
a very human emotion but like you don't
need to feel that because honestly it's
just sex it's not even sex it's I mean
it's sex but it's like naughty videos
and you're a [ __ ] grown-up you know
yeah she says she's 30 right yeah yeah
you know you're 30.
in your 30s like you're a full ass adult
you can do whatever the [ __ ] your mom
directly in her eyes and say my bean
needed attention am I what you look at
your mom right in the eyes and you like
say it like Mr Mr Anderson in the
[ __ ] Matrix okay might be needed
attention what word are you saying being
my being needed yeah what's that well it
looks like a bean on your body in
between your legs like a coffee bean
okay no no well
it looks like a lentil bean up top I
don't think it looks like it looks like
a coffee bean the actual thing looks
like a coffee bean but I'm saying oh oh
the lentil bean up top
lentil bean oh okay
there's a lentil being on top of a
coffee bean if you know what I'm cutting
there's a big coffee bean it's like a
Russian doll there's a there's a big
coffee bean but I'm saying actual sized
lentil being above the big coffee bean
that's the bean that needed attention
really because I got it that was
pleasure LL Bean okay so what you need
to do
is realize that your mom also needed to
attend to her being at some point uh
that everyone in the world attends to
their beans that's why in all the old
ass [ __ ] religious texts it says
nobody is allowed God said nobody's
allowed to play with their beans yeah
okay it should have been everyone loved
you know it's okay to attend to your
beings
tender beans
wow that's good the 11th commandment and
it's okay to attend to your beans you
shall always attend to your neighbor's
beings all the Commandments have to do
with their neighbor you know yeah yeah I
know that's so weird just make sure you
are not hooked up to your neighbor's
Bluetooth as well yeah only be hooked up
to your own Bluetooth when you attend
when being attentive to your being or
just attending to your beans right
I think I got the language right yeah I
mean it doesn't really matter because
it's not real but yeah
okay anyway okay just own it dude you
[ __ ] attended to your being and you
got caught I needed to lightly move my
being around also what's with the mom
yeah I noticed like what a dick dude
she's just she got all pent up she needs
to [ __ ] hang with her being a little
bit dude you should send her the video
uh air drop the video to her and say
yeah being attendance is required yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true being
attendance required comma mom yeah
being attendance in the email
she sees this to other people and gets
she's just so bad with technology oh no
all right yeah for sure all right I'm
gonna take a pure Spectrum gummies dude
huh keeps me level-headed baby oh you
know it's always been one of my least
favorite things that you do but you put
something in your mouth you go keep your
love ahead of babies [ __ ]
[Music]
pure Spectrum CBD the link is in the
show notes go down click it hit Lifeline
for 10 off of all your CBD needs my
babies
hello
hello hello hello
[Music]